نعم حمزه كما اشرتم تفصلنا سويعات قليله
على انطلاق هذه المباراه ومن الان هناك
اجواء حماسيه في محيط ملعب خليفه الدولي
شاهدنا العديد من الجماهير البريطانيه
وايضا هناك عدد كبير من الجماهير
الايرانيه طبعا الكل يعول على فوز واضح
اليوم لتمهيد الطريق للمرور الى الدور
الثاني معنا همم المشجع الانجليزي همم
الدوحه الذي سيحدثنا عن حظوظ المنتخب
الانجليزي اليوم همم
المنتخب همم
كاس العالم في قطر هل تتوقع الفوز لمنتخب
الكون اليوم هل نعم للدوره الثانيه
بين مقابل لا شيء اتمنى نرى امام اخرك ما
كان شان بالنسبه لمباراه لكره القدم ايه
ده لم تتاهل انجلترا اللي هي الدوره
الثانيه اليوم هل ستتقد انها مستقبل ساويد
سيكون في كاس افريقيا
ان اليوم هو الوقت
شكرا جزيلا طبعا
المنتخب الانجليزي هو من ابرز المرشحين
للفوز بهذه الكاس ولكن ايران ايضا اليوم
تعول على تحقيق انجاز تاريخي في هذه
المجموعه السهله نسبيا بالنسبه لبعض
المنتخبات ولذلك بطعم الجماهيري كبير كما
اشرت معنا همم امير همم
سكس همم
ايران هذه المره ستتاهل الدوره الثانيه
ونحن تاهل للمره الرابعه وليا لكاس العالم
المرات
الماضيه كانت اذا ما شئت اختبار لكن هذه
المره لدينا معنويه كبيره وتجربه معكوس
العالم ومجموعه من اللاعبين يلعبون على
على المستويات
الاوروبيه
مع المنتخب امريكا
طبعا ايران تعول اليوم على الظهور اللامع
ان صح
التعبير لا ينصحت تعبير للنجم الفريق الذي
يلعب في فريق
نعم حمزه